ce sont des images qui tournent sur
internet depuis quelques heures et qui
ont de quoi choquer les images d'une
intervention musclée de la part des
forces de l'ordre que beaucoup décrivent
d'ores et déjà comme une bavure
policière
celle en quête de l'outsider qui a
révélé cette histoire celle de michel un
producteur de musique qui dirige black
gold corp studio qui a été roué de coups
par trois policiers samedi dernier à
paris selon sa version il serait sorti
sans masque devant son studio
voyant arriver une voiture de police il
aurait fait demi-tour et aurait tenté de
rentrer à nouveau dans son studio pour
éviter une amende
c'est aussi à ce moment là que pour une
raison inconnue les policiers ont roué
de coups le producteur finalement à
l'extérieur les policiers tentent à
nouveau de rentrer dans les locaux
eh ben on m'envoie une grenade convoi
pour les manifestants encore une fois à
l'extérieur du bâtiment
les collègues qui travaillent avec le
producteur et qui ont tenté de le
défendre sont eux aussi frappé et mis à
terre une scène à laquelle des voisins
assistent en filmant des caméras qui
aurait eu un effet dissuasif
après 48 heures de garde à vue pour
outrages violences sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
rébellion michel et remis en liberté
finalement suite à la publication de ces
images et six jours d'itt et et pour
michel
le parquet de paris a décidé de classer
sans suite les charges contre lui
pour ce qui est des fonctionnaires de
police mis en cause toujours selon le
parquet de paris une enquête a été
ouverte par l'igpn la police des polices
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur a lui aussi réagi sur
twitter
je me félicite que l'igpn était été
saisi par la justice dès mardi
je demande au préfet de police de
suspendre à titre conservatoire les
policiers concernés
je souhaite que la procédure
disciplinaire puisse être conduite dans
les plus brefs délais une affaire qui
intervient en pleine polémique sur la
loi autour de la sécurité globale
michel est avec nous ce soir
merci michel d'être là merci beaucoup
merci m afida et laly d'être là merci
beaucoup
alors michel on va revenir à ce soir du
21 novembre
vous arrivez dans votre local dans le
xviie arrondissement de paris
et c'est vrai que vous allez raconter
l'histoire pour ce qu'ils n'ont pas vu
et pour nos téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent en direct ce soir à 21h moi
j'ai halluciné de l'histoire donc vous
êtes tranquille pour entrer dans votre
studio c'était le 21 novembre
oui je vais pas rentrer dans mes studios
et quand j'ouvre la porte pour entrer
internement studio je sens une une
présence après comme je l'expliquais aux
policiers je ne suis même pas savoir si
on me tire on me pousse dans mon studio
mais toujours est il qu'on se retrouve
ensuite dans mon studio qui est un lieu
privé donc je préviens les policiers je
leur dis que tout simplement ce qu'ils
veulent alors vous n'aviez pas de masque
non je n'avais pas de masque donc vous
passez dans la rue vous les voyez les
policiers avant de rentrer dans le sud
ont évolué je mène à masquer ou pas du
tout alors je je je les aperçois
mais c'est en train de rouler en ville
sans voitures donc il passe devant moi
mais moi je continue ma route 50 mètres
de mon studio d'accord donc là vous
rentrez dans vos studios et là vous
sentez que une présence derrière vous il
ya des gens qui rentrent avec vous
exactement
et là on a vu les images donc très vite
il ya un des policiers je vois qui
commencent à vous agresser mais ce qui
vous demande quelque chose qui vous
disent vos skis vous demander vos
papiers
est-ce qu'il vous demande pas si vous ne
provenait pas de masquer ce qu'il essaie
de discuter avec vous ou direct il vous
agresse non c'est très agressif tout de
suite là tout de suite je me prends des
ta gueule parce que j'essaye de savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe vous leur dites
moi vous leur demander mais qu'est ce
qui se passe
oui bien sûr tout de suite je demande de
jeu ma je sais le truc c'est que moi
j'arrive notre studio je m'attends pas à
ce qu'on dit derrière moi ou quoi que ce
soit donc quand ils viennent vraiment et
puis ils me demandent de sortir je me
demande pourquoi
et c'est là que c'est très agressif ta
gueule et puis d'autres à suspense et à
des insultes à caractère racial mais
sale [ __ ] ça qu'on lui a dit très grave
n'arrivait même pas le dire non il ya
des familles des enfants qui regardent
au bout d'un moment voilà c'est à ces
écrits qu'est-ce qui vous ont reproché à
rien jusqu'à aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
ce qu'ils me reprochent
je sais pas ce qui me reprocher c'est
parce qu'ils voulaient je ne sais même
bien bien que je les voie moi c'est ça
ouais donc y en a qui en civil et en
civil que joue en premier et puis après
très vite je vois je vois les deux
autres habillant en policier mais vous
essayé de leur parler vous l'essayez de
leur dire mais je suis exclu à ce que
j'ai fait je sais que sa série 6 fois je
leur demande pourquoi genre demande
beaucoup pourquoi en fait oui c'est ça
je garde toujours les mains
c'est ce que vous dites dans la vidéo
sur le site books haider vous dites pas
que je ne sais pas du tout dans
l'agressivité
parce que je veux pas vraiment qu'on
croit que j'ai pu attaquer les policiers
j'ai pu je crois que les on le voit dans
la vidéo vous êtes extrêmement calme
extrêmement dos ils jugent en caisse
voilà c'est ça et vous dit à un moment
je veux rester absolument debout parce
que si je me trouve
si je me mets à terre j'ai peur de plus
jamais relevé vous avez eu très très
peur a eu très très peur
ah oui parce que je sais que je il ne
faut pas rendre des coups et je sais
qu'il faut que les enquêtes
ça fait mal mais des coups de matraque
des coups de rangers dans les tibias
vous recevez plus de vingt coups de
points 10 coups de pied ont cinq minutes
des coups de genou de matraque vous fait
étrangler doigt sur vous vous essayez de
comprendre d'escroquerie y allait d'un
moment parce que vous savez voiliers qui
a plus rien à faire vous crier à l'aide
quelles aides je crie appelé la police
mais c'est fou est-ce que vous avez cru
que c'était des faux policiers ce que
vous dites vous dit peut-être que sinon
ça m'a traversé l'esprit mais tout va
tellement vite que après jeu
reste debout michel c'est ce que je me
dis m afida elle a dit on va on va
continuer le témoignage de michel dans
un instant mais tous les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent tous les gens qui ont
suivi cette histoire aujourd'hui se pose
une seule et unique question pourquoi et
ils disent mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce que qu'est ce qui a pu
se passer dans la tête des policiers en
acharnement vous ont agressé par moments
il ya des jaunes ou le platine ont pris
pour quelqu'un d'autre
c'était celle ci c'est complètement
incroyable là ici c'est qu'est-ce que je
ne saurais vous répondre je ne suis pas
moi-même dans leur tête
bien sûr mais tout ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui ces déclarations quand je
mangeais pu enfin dont les services de
police ont pu me faire état lors de
l'audition de mon client
d'accord ce qu'il était en garde à vue
mais je n'ai rien d'autre c'est
l'officier de police judiciaire qui nous
demandait si de confirmer ou non les
déclarations des des plaignants et
aucune de leurs déclarations bien
évidemment nous concorde et tente avec
la réalité de mon client qu'avec
l'évident la vidéosurveillance alors il
savait pas qu'il y avait une
vidéosurveillance impose désormais ça
donc vous une fois que on va revenir sur
l'histoire ou à vous appeler à l'aide
puisqu'il y avait des jeunes artistes en
bas de votre studio mais qui était en
train d'enregistrer dont ils n'entendent
pas tout de suite parce que il est en
train d'enregistrer donc forcément il y
avait énormément de bruit
la trois portes que nous qui ne se
parlent plus y est c'est pour regarder
un bon son dans les studios donc
forcément c'est extrêmement bien isolée
donc exercer à nouveau entendue quand
même et vous appeler à l'aide
michel et au bout d'un moment les jeunes
font une pause ils entendent ils montent
donc pour voir ce qui se passe et là ils
vouvoient à être agressés par des
policiers entendent surtout quand ils
entendent les insultes il entend les
bruits des coûts faut savoir que
des mineurs ils sont c'est tout c'est
sûr il y avait des jeunes dès 16 ans oui
c'est celle des jeunes qui sont là qui
sont devant moi je je je m'occupe de
deux jeunes artistes et je voudrais dire
aux téléspectateurs michel c'est un
producteur extrêmement respectée c'est
quelqu'un qui fait son travail depuis
des années qui fait un travail très bon
travail qui est très très reconnu dans
le milieu
voilà il n'avait jamais eu aucun souci
et vous avez poussé de nombreux jeunes
d'ailleurs à réaliser lorraine et à
faire ce métier qui était le rêve allait
pouvoir chanter pouvoir côtoyer de
grands artistes
et c'est vrai que là ils vous voient ils
voient leur leurs producteurs en train
de se faire tabasser
ça a été qu à leurs actions je pense
déjà quand il poussait la porte on est
que le policier bloquer la porte
je pense qu avec l'adrénaline tout ça
ils m'ont déjà il voulait ouvrir la
porte voir ce qui se passe bien sûr et
caen 1 2 arrive à ouvrir la porte
ce qui m'a sauvé quelque part à ce que
vous pensez que justement là que la
question qu'on se posait j'ai vu un
tweet de mon ami benjamin béni le joueur
de foot qui a twitté concernant votre
affaire qu'elle dit qu'est ce qui se
serait passé si les jeunes ou n'avait
pas entendu
est ce que pensent et michel que votre
vie aurait été en danger
absolument penser que là il aurait pu ne
pas s'arrêter
je ne pense pas qu'ils avaient
l'intention de s'arrêter en tout cas en
tout cas pas comme ils se sont arrêtés
quand la porte ça commençait à souffrir
quand ils ont senti qu'il y avait une
pression ce que les jeunes et ils
étaient neuf en bas ça dure et qu'en
même temps mon temps à la 10 à 12
minutes neku correspondrait à 7 minutes
une sinon 100 minutes ce sont les
souffre et sûrement encaissés c'est
incroyable et les trois vous taper
dessus des 3 me taper dessus
alors donc les jeunes arrivent a ouvert
la porte ils arrivent là les policiers
par exemple arrivent déjà et voit de dos
police se serait en fait qu'ils vont
essayer le bol c'est quand ils voient
police ça les rassure pas ah bah là on
s'est plu parce qu'en fait quand ils
sont quand après ça quand les polices
consorts et que
et pousser voit la police ils poussent
le policier et que les policiers sortent
il faut appeler quelqu'un qu'on appelle
qui la police vous appelez la police
en tout cas les les jeunes c'est bon on
à cette réflexion
moi je n'appelle pas la police mais on a
cette réflexion c'est donc vous mettez
la premier nord et vous appelez la
police vraiment bas c'est que j'ai un
voisin par exemple qui a entendu le
tout ce bruit qui m'appellent et qui me
dit j'entends du bruit qu'est-ce qui se
passe judy on se fait agresser et me
disent appelle la police et là je répond
instinctivement c'est la police qui est
là c'est donc honnêtement c'est un peu
ce canyon ski 1 d'autres policiers qui
sont venus qui n'avait rien à voir avec
la sphère qui sont sains et qui ont
intervenu après ou pas du tout ben quand
quand les policiers sont sortis ils ont
foncé mois appelé du renfort à la gloire
donc ce n'était pas les policiers vous
aviez appelé vous annoncez des points
ici qu'ils sont venus en renfort pour
aider les policiers à les agresser
sauf qu est ce qui se passe là je
construise non il n'existe pas des
policiers agressés oui ils sont là mais
on vienne pourrait y viennent pour
soutenir leurs amis parce que vu que
quand ils les appellent les bains je les
aurai agressé alors justement parce que
c'est là que l'histoire est incroyable
c'est que donc ces policiers qui vous
ont régressé appellent des renforts et
leur disent on s'est fait agresser venez
vite on a besoin de renforts c'est ça
donc et vous y les font venir dans le
17e arrondissement il ya votre studio
oui donc là les autres policiers
connexion n'ont rien à voir avec
l'histoire
parce que voilà ce soir il va y avoir
une enquête bien entendu on va en parler
avec heure avec m hafid al ahly mais
c'est vrai que là ce qu'on se dit c'est
que ce genre
nos policiers ils font énormément de mal
à ce qu'ils font bien leur travail
exactement c'est ça que je pense voilà
aujourd'hui je sais que vous avez été la
police des polices oui pour porter
plainte et j'ai sûr que vous avez été
accueillis bien sûr extrêmement bien
vous allez nous raconter mais ça c'est
un fléau pour la majeure partie des
policiers totalement dans ce sens à leur
travail et je suis avec qui vous n'avez
jamais eu aucun problème
bien sûr je suis totalement d'accord
avec toi juste donc là vous êtes dans le
studio ils vont sortir et par équipes on
est son récepteur c'est pour ces pour
les jeunes et encore aujourd'hui je sais
pas s'ils sont sortis avant moi ou après
moi parce que quand ils ont lancé la
grenade
oui vous ont lancé une grenade
lacrymogène a simplement dans votre
studio là vous avez pris peur parce que
vous êtes dit peut-être que ça va me
lancer dehors ça bien sûr moi y'a quoi
il ya cinquante mille karim zaoui look
l'aï lancé une grenade lacrymogène pour
que vous sortiez oui la question vous
faites moi je vais dans le fond mon
studio
c'est ça oui et là vous décidez quand
même vous désirez faire quoi je bats là
je respire plus ouais j'ai mon téléphone
dans les mains et je décide enfin je ne
décide pas j'appelle qui je peux en fait
les mon avocat j'essaie d'appeler mon
avocat je pars mais d'ores et déjà
michel m'a appelé à ce moment là
justement j'étais en ligne et tout ce
que j'ai dans mon répondeur c'est un
souffle de lui oui dix anneaux à l'eau
et la ccc j'ai eu un sentiment de
culpabilité alors ça bien sûr ap par son
associé valérie atlan oui dix minutes
après donc je me sentais coupable de ne
pas avoir été là alors qu'en réalité de
la vérité je n'aurais pas pu intervenir
la même manière donc là michel qui se
passe en classe vous vous appelez votre
avocat elle peut pas répondre aller l on
line vous faites quoi jeu après jeu
j'entends les puces et qui me disent de
qu'une demande de sortir d'accord moi
c'est raide très honnêtement à ce moment
là je je je regarde comme ça et je vois
quelqu'un qui me braque et qui se cache
derrière
ensuite ça veut dire que tout de suite
je me dis maintenant si mme barati c'est
lui qui a une arme et qu'il se cache
c'est qu'ils pensent que je suis armé
aussi j'ai peur à normaliser sortir
jeudi je sors pas je j'ai peur et je le
redis j'ai peur je ne sors pas j'ai peur
et vous dise quoi sort là vous vous
faites quoi vous finissez par sortir
c'est ils viennent
je vois un policier je vois un policier
qui s'avance donc je le vois dans la
fumée je montre mes mains et là je sors
et puis après il m'attrape à deux ou
trois et puis je je je les suis dehors
il ya une fois dehors qu'est ce qui se
passe dans ma vie je crois que jamais je
n'ai vécu quelque chose comme ça en fait
jamais de la vie
jamais vécu quelque chose comme ça je me
suis pris tellement de coups doit encore
j'ai je suis censé avoir agressé leurs
collègues arrêts donc si vous avez vu le
dispositif qui a été mis en place
donc là ils vont passer à tabac oui on
voit le policier qui était un des
policiers qui étaient qui fait partie
des trois qui montent dessus et puis à
moi j'en profite je me permet de
rebondir lorsque valérie m'appelle
lorsque valérie m'appelle l'associé de
michel associé de michel effectivement
elle me demandait me dit ça casse sont
les jeunes
artistes qui étaient en bas qui l'ont
informé en fait on tape michel hôte
affichait alors qu'il est en train de se
faire frapper dans le sas donc je
démarrais je vais directement sur les
lieux tout tout le monde est parti il
n'y a que deux policiers
est ce que je découvre en premier c'est
une mare de sang
c'est lorsque les policiers justement le
prennent à partie à terre qu'il est
sûrement été blessées ou en tout cas moi
je découvre une mare de sang de michel
que je connais depuis très longtemps je
vois également un conte un trou en fait
au niveau de la fenêtre alors au départ
je vois un coup je vois juste un tronc
en fait je crois que ça attire c'est par
là qu'ils ont c'est la première chose
non la grenade ils l'ont fait ils l'ont
éjecté par la porte d'accès ans voilà
mais lorsque l'on voit un tronc et puis
une mare de sang et deux policiers
demandent actuellement du clip et on
s'inquiète énormément
michel je me sens extrêmement touché
encore un assureur histoire où est donc
là qu'est ce qui se passe il vous amène
au commissariat et m'amène au
commissariat d'aix à tous les jeunes que
vous avec tous les jeunes je m'excuse
encore auprès d'eux j'étais jeune à
garder ce n'est pas à vous excuser
ils sont chez moi je suis responsable de
ré mais c'est vous pouvez faire le
ménage chez mozart folie de certaines
personnes gimbert chez moi donc quand
quand tous ces jeunes sont chez moi ils
sont sur ma responsabilité
ouais mais là dans lequel pouvait rien
faire je vous dis oui mais le fait est
qu'il soit quand même à sable de la
folie de certaines personnes voient même
sous ma responsabilité quoi qu'on en
dise alors donc vous allez tous au
commissariat qu'est ce qui se passe pour
les jeunes ils sont relâchés et rient
ils sont lâchés
quand je pars à l'hôpital pour me poser
deux agrafes et puis me soigner les
petites blessures et couplé sur une
grosse blessure quand on a vu les photos
ouais ça grave michel juste quand vous
arrivez au commissariat c'est quoi la
version qui est donné par les politiques
parce que une version pour laquelle vous
êtes interpellé c'est toi on débute
d'ailleurs je ne fais que la demande et
maïs et ça on a tous envie de savoir la
version des policiers
je joue à savoir pourquoi enfin pourquoi
c'est arrivé je tout le monde là
aujourd'hui on parle de masques je sais
même pas si c'est ça le truc jeux
d'ambiance ou pire derby non mais ça me
retiens n'a pas de marge et bien voilà
il a une annonce à rudy 2 mai mais là on
en vient on part demandé dans des
délires la foudre sur un coin juste ils
disent qu'ils disent pas c'est quoi leur
version que vous avez vous avez lu le
leur leur apostolat lorsqu'une personne
est en garde à vue puisqu'il est placé
en garde à vue on lui reproche des
rebellions ainsi que des violences sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique serait également le d'avoir
tenté de prendre son arme larmes des
policiers pendant les faits on lui
reproche sa initialement ennuis notifie
ses droits dans des circonstances je
viendrai pas trop rallonger le débat
mais concrètement il a demandé mes
services
on m'a jamais appelé on n'a jamais
appelé alors que c'est son droit le
premier notifie ses droits c'est droit
d'avoir un avis de droit d'avoir un
médecin pendant on interprète
éventuellement pour les étrangers on lui
a pas notifié ces droits-là donc d'ores
et déjà moi même lorsque je suis
intervenu au commissariat on me demande
ce que je fais là comme angers comment
j'ai su ce qui se passait mais avec m
vous quel est votre hypothèse sur ce qui
s'est passé parce que alors moi j'ai
fait ce qu'il sait pas s'il reproche ces
violences et lorsque on le dit sione mon
client on qui indique sa version 2008 à
turin donc c'est une des premières
questions c'est parler de ce qui vous
amène ici
et puis on
la version des policiers alors la
version des policiers avec les auditions
ce policier pendant c'est monsieur
michel parent dont les attirer dans le
studio
je rappelle qu'ils sont comme on le voit
dans les vidéos qu'ils rentrent eux
mêmes un succès inégal déjà ces eaux
sont tout de suite dans l'illégalité
il indique également qu' il étire envers
les studios accrochez vous il est
modeste et 3 puis 3 il est visé il tente
de lui prendre son arme
ils appellent du renfort
ce sont leur terme en main sur lui il se
retrouve dans un guet-apens jeu reprend
les termes de l'audition fou met donc la
halle et là les policiers quand ils ont
donné leur version ils savaient pas
qu'ils avaient déjà il savait pas assez
ça savais pas qu'il y avait des caméras
est là michel vous vous dégainez les
caméras très vite les caméras de
surveillance ou de chute -2 dès que
j'entends tout ça je sais que j'ai la
première audition en fait je me résigne
1 c'est en fait lors de l'audition mon
client bien évidemment nie l'ensemble
des faits qui lui sont de chercher et
les comptes est entièrement et l'aï dit
au pays lundi
quoi qu'il en soit vous avez bien
évidemment une caméra qui est située
exactement à l'angle de là où on y est
né et graves violences michèle ce qui
s'est passé alors il va avoir une
enquête on peut pas voilà pour l'instant
on peut passer sa vie à m mais je sais
que vous êtes un garçon voile avec des
amis en commun extrêmement joyeux
extrêmement voilà vous aimez la vie vous
êtes heureux de ce que vous faites vous
éclater dans votre métier
je sens vraiment que là vous avez pris
psychologiquement bien à part les coups
vous avez pris qui ont été violents
vraiment ça vous a mis à terre j'ai
envie de dire plus à terre que les coûts
je ne te met un mois juin de bagneux
d'accord aujourd'hui j'ai des studios
dans le 17e arrondissement lors pour les
téléspectateurs banio c'est une banlieue
imola aurésienne exactement le 17ème
arrondissement sis au quartier voilà
dans le dix septième jeu
une jeunesse assez chaotique ouais je
suis passé par la case prison
je suis sorti de ça il ya 15 ans et
depuis j'ai tout fait pour que vous
soyez soit viable
c'est l'homme que je suis aujourd'hui
non ça gêne les gens je je je suis fier
de produire tous ces artistes les
artistes qui étaient là de données sous
bois qui je suis je suis hyper fier de
ça je on a fait ensemble l'âge d'or du
rap français on a fait ensemble secteur
à moi comme égérie ciel qu ait connue
dans le métier qui a jamais eu un souci
depuis des années des années
bien sûr et qui est fier de fêter de
faire ce qu'il fait et de fier d'être là
où il est aujourd'hui après ce qu'il a
traversé bien sûr c'est une victoire
aussi pour le métier voter pour les
jeunes voilà alors qu'ils que vous
produisez aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il
ya beaucoup d'émotion parce que ce que
j'ai vu est ce qu'on a eu pas ce que
c'est c'est extrêmement prenant est ce
que vous avez réussi ce que vous avez
revu ses ses agresseurs fait qu'ils
appellent ses agresseurs maintenant ce
que vous les avez revu est-ce que vous
qu'est ce qui va se passer m il devait
après son audition être confronté avec
les plaignants juste après d'accord
devaient se succéder à la confrontation
finalement ils ne sont pas venus on m'a
indiqué qu'ils étaient aux umj d'accord
ça a été déplacé au lendemain n'ont pas
eu lieu les perquisitions pardon aux
studios qui permettait de découvrir le
système de vidéosurveillance et compte
tenu de ce que l'on découvrait nord
fausses déclarations du fait des vidéos
de surveillance
ils n'ont ils ont refusé la
confrontation ce sont eux qui ont refusé
la confrontation ce qui est extrêmement
rare et c'est rare et c'est tout à fait
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses arrive
effectivement que des femmes bien sûr il
ans refuse de voir leurs bourreaux leurs
agresseurs mais là sont des policiers
qui ne devrait pas avoir michel vous est
ce que vous êtes parce que comme
l'histoire est folle est ce que vous
êtes sorti d'affaires vous j'ai envie de
dire juridiquement parlant
judiciairement parlant presque voilà ce
qui est une plainte contre vous de ces
policiers ou pas du tout non là
aujourd'hui ce que j'en sais c'est que
le procureur
à classer l affaire concerne vous
concernant hawks et ça c'est déjà une
nouvelle abordable voilà c'est sa
plainte ça oui parce qu'il ya eu des
plaintes avec eux je me permet de rouler
extrêmement grave
il ya eu trois plaintes et les umj
unités médico judiciaires
ce sont les médecins qui sont chargés de
constater d'éventuelles blessures ainsi
que leurs conséquences ont constaté cinq
jours d'itt été pour un des policiers et
deux fois un jour pour l'autre voilà où
on peut que s'interroger sur vocation
d'origine lyonnaise corps étendus et
surtout si elles ont été conçues indiqué
par un médecin c'est qu'elles ont été
effectivement sur la tête je suis dien
bien évidemment pas du tout bon mon
client 1 sur 10 des jeunes vous avez
porté plainte aujourd'hui à la police
des policiers voilà donc qu'est-ce qui
vous ont dit bon l'enquète va ils vont
faire une enquête là-dessus avec bien
sûr tous les éléments qui leur avait
fourni vos témoignages
ok une enquête administrative ainsi
qu'une enquête judiciaire
d'accord alors vous avez vu que même le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
darmanin a réagi heureusement
aujourd'hui et le président aussi tout
le monde a ravi on dit voilà qu'ils
allaient suivre
l'anc est ce que vous avez été contacté
par des membres du gouvernement ou par
le président m pour l'instant michel
hadji tous d'accord là on voit on a fait
défiler des tweets a pas parlé beaucoup
de gens ont réagi michel je vais fermer
loyalistes excusez moi
ministre de l'intérieur indiqué qu'ils
étaient suspendus provisoirement
d'accord et heureusement j'ai envie de
vous sait déjà ce monument oui aussi et
surtout l'anc est qui étaient ouverts à
l'igpn n'a été fait qu'une fois que les
vidéos sont officiellement sortis
bah oui d'accord voilà c'est une chose a
précisé autrement dit la parole demain
clients on ne suffisait pas voilà et
d'adresser les vidéos qui ont fait
qu'elle peut avoir cette démarche
exotisme la parole de mon client va les
moins que celle les policiers qui ont
dès le départ était entendue michel je
voudrais te remercier d'être venus ce
soir j'étais vraiment très touché parce
qu'ils étaient arrivés
j'espère vraiment que tu vas réussir à
te reconstruire enfin parce qu'à vite
voilà essayer de de penser à autre chose
de continuer à ce que tu veux faire ce
que tu fais pas ce que tu fais un
travail admirable avec ton associés en
indépendant voilà non mais c'est vrai
c'est pas évident voilà ce que tu fais
et j'espère vraiment que ça à pas mettre
un frein à tout ce que tu as construit à
tous que à tout ce que tu as construit
même dans ta tête au la personne que tu
es devenu et est ce que tu as un message
tête à faire passer aujourd'hui je sais
pas si c'est un message mais en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est que je veux pas
qu'on confonde les choses c'est à dire
que j'ai été agressé par trois personnes
je moi je crois en la justice je crois
en notre police est et je veux pas qu'on
confonde ce vraiment ces trois personnes
là pour moi en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne ne sont pas dignes de ces gens
qui doivent me protéger a joint un
uniforme c'est censé nous protéger sa
pas été le cas
je veux vraiment con ce conte pour ma
part qu on se dise pas que kim et tous
les policiers dans le dans le dans le
même bateau même ceux qui sont arrivés
par la suite servi par les déclarations
des versions donc forcément avec des
hommes des avions bi qui a oui je sais
pas ce que c'est vraiment important pour
moi j'ai des amis pour les symboles
bravo de le dire bravo avait pas de
policier et j'oserais dire quelque chose
tous les jeunes qui nous regardent ce
soir le le message de michel il est très
important
ce soir ne rentrait pas dans une haine
des policiers de la police de la
gendarmerie des forces de l'ordre c'est
encore une fois des brebis galeuses
comme on les appelle dans tous les
métiers y en a partout
michel ça a été une des victimes
j'ai une aura une enquête et ce que je
vois c'est vrai que ça a l'air édifiant
mais il y aura une enquête s'était
victimes de ces personnes qui font mal
leur travail mais 90% - la police et moi
j'ai des potes policiers aussi vous en
avez vous avez dit j'ai des potes qui
sont en prison on est plein voilà qui
nous regardent tous les soirs que
j'embrasse d'ailleurs aussi voilà qui
sont sortis de prison qui se sont
réinsérés et qui essayait d'être
irréprochables justes les jeunes ne
tombez pas dans la haine mais les
policiers notent ses formes et des
forces de l'ordre
ça ce sont des personnes qui sont ici
ont qu un comportement inadmissible et
j'espère que l' enquête va déterminer
voilà leurs responsabilités et qu'ils
vont être sévèrement punis mais c'est
vraiment voilà je vous dise ça
représente une infime minorité de ce que
sont les policiers et les forces de
l'ordre
michel je vais dire bravo pour ton
parcours j'espère que tu vas voilà
pouvoir passer à autre chose pouvoir
continuer à travailler comme tu le fais
et à sortir des jeunes et à leur faire
réaliser leurs rêves
et tu sais que je serai toujours là pour
toi et si tu as besoin d'une antenne de
quelque chose tu sais très bien que le
plateau il est toujours ouvert pour toi
et pour ôter artistes
[Applaudissements]